ein freibad in berlin familien mit
kindern und plötzlich bricht eine
massenschlägerei unter rund 100 jungen
männern aus die polizei muss mit 13
funkwagen anrücken das war am wochenende
und die frage ist war das ein einzelfall
ein problem bad in berlin oder können
sich auch in anderen großstädten
familien mit kindern nicht mehr in
freibäder hineinwagen unserer reporter
sind dieser frage nachgegangen
der harmlose anlass ein bespritzen mit
wasserpistolen das ergebnis rund 100
personen schlagen aufeinander ein
mehrere verletzte und ein polizei
großeinsatz
wird die polizei am montag mitteilt
kommt es am sonntagnachmittag zu einer
massenschlägerei in einem sommerbad im
berliner bezirk steglitz demnach sollen
sich gegen 16 uhr 25 zunächst zwei
gruppen bestehend aus vier und zehn
personen im spaß mit wasserpistolen
bespritzt haben allerdings entwickelt
sich aus dem anfänglichen spaß erst eine
verbale und dann eine körperliche
auseinandersetzung
es war eine tolle ausgelassene stimmung
und plötzlich bildete sich halt ein
großer pulk aber ich muss auch sagen der
sicherheit ziehen zwar sehr schnell vor
ort und es kam halt zur
auseinandersetzung zu rangeleien als
sicherheitskräfte schlichten wollen
eskaliert die situation am ende sind an
der massenschlägerei rund 100 leute
beteiligt alles festgehalten in mehreren
videos die person die ich erzähle im
moment haben keinen respekt mehr vor
leuten und wenn ich dann auch noch zum
ausdruck welche vorwiegend leute mit
migrationshintergrund sehe also auch
verschiedene kulturelle neben dann muss
ich sagen das kann somit weiter geht der
horror vor allem für familien die mit
ihren kindern den heißen sonntag mit
spaß im freibad verbringen wollen als
die schlägerei zwischen den rund 100
jungen männern ausbricht stehen kinder
im pulk im hintergrund sieht man wie
mütter aufspringen ihre kinder in
sicherheit bringen also ich hätte keine
lust mit meiner familie mich in einem
solchen freibad zu befinden wo ein
solches chaos
ist es vielleicht abbild auch was in der
gesellschaft sich an entwicklung an der
einen oder anderen stelle zeigen
ermittlungen vor ort führen zunächst zu
vier tatverdächtigen im alter von 23
zweimal 21 und 15 jahren
gegen die vier wird nun wegen besonders
schweren landfriedensbruchs ermittelt
gegen einen 21 jährigen wird zudem wegen
gefährlicher körperverletzung ermittelt
er soll auf einen sicherheits
mitarbeiter des schwimmbades
eingeschlagen haben ein zehnjähriger
junge der in die aggressive gruppe
geriet bekam einen faustschlag gegen den
kopf ab
[Musik]
wir sind verbunden mit rainer wendt
vorsitzender der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft
wendt
erwähnt ist das ein berliner einzelfall
oder sind solche probleme auch aus
anderen städten bekannt
leider ist das kein berliner ein zufall
das ist zwar ein exzessiver in aus
anderen städten auch kennen und auch aus
den vergangenen jahren fast könnte man
sagen und jährlich grüßt das murmeltier
das wetter wird besser und wir erleben
diese szenen in freibädern leider nicht
nur in berlin was sind die ursachen
na ja wissen sie solche gewaltexzesse
haben immer viele ursachen und deshalb
kann man nicht sagen man könnte auf den
einen oder anderen knopf drücken und
schon hat man das problem im griff aber
eine feststellung muss man schon treffen
wenn wie in diesem fall der betreiber
des freibades einlädt zur kids pool
party das heißt ausdrücklich eine
veranstaltung die an kinder und familien
mit kindern gerichtet sind und er lässt
dann
männer in einer großen anzahl und aus
einem bestimmten milieu in diesem
freitag hinein dann darf man sich nicht
wundern wenn das nicht funktioniert hier
hätte mehr sorgfalt an den tag gelegt
werden müssen was der anlass kontrollen
angeht der vorsitzende der bademeister
gesellschaft der deutschen sprachen
davon dass es viele junge männer mit
migrationshintergrund waren das immer
problematisch dass so auszusprechen
sehen sie das auch so
ja ich sehe das genauso das ist ja sehr
augenscheinlich es sind nicht alle aber
es gibt ausdruck auf augenscheinlich
viele die einen augenscheinlichen
migrationshintergrund haben und ich
wünschte mir dass die forschung die ja
sehr eifrig dabei ist permanent die
polizei zu erforschen auch hier einmal
etwas eifer an den tag legt er und
einmal ihr augenmerk darauf richtet wie
so etwas eigentlich passiert und vor
allen dingen warum es passiert warum
junge männer aus diesem milieu für sich
den öffentlichen raum beanspruchen denn
darum scheint es ja zu gehen das gibt
das gab es auch an anderen
veranstaltungen man erinnert sich an die
kölner silvesternacht an den gardasee an
viele andere veranstaltungen wo
urplötzlich eine große gruppe männer
meistens oder häufig mit
migrationshintergrund auftauchen und den
öffentlichen raum für sich beanspruchen
er und dort gewalttätig werden bei
dieser szene kann man sagen da hat es
dann nur noch eines zündfunken gebraucht
bis die aufeinander losgehen das ist
dann leider so aber die polizei wird das
nicht lösen können das müssen die
betreiber lösen sie müssen
einlasskontrollen machen und man sagen
wir nicht das funktioniert nicht das
funktioniert an jeder diskothek auch
diejenigen die das hausrecht ausüben
müssen dafür sorgen dass das publikum
das die der einlass so kontrolliert wird
dass das publikum eben nicht so
beschaffen ist wie das hier aussieht
sagt rainer wendt vorsitzender der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft vielen
events